difficile de croire qu'ici dans trois
ans un nouveau pôle de santé de 25 mille
mètres carrés remplacera l'ancienne
station de martinique la première n'est
pour l'heure le site est en l'état les
tractopelles sont à l'arrêt et pour
cause les 200 prélèvements effectués sur
les lieux révèle une forte présence
d'amiante le bâtiment le plus récent ce
qui vous allez voir qui est enveloppé y
est là uniquement sur la peinture
extérieure est par contre les plus
anciens bâtiments ce que vous voyez ici
sont amiante et d'une façon sévère aussi
bien l'extérieur qu'à l'intérieur que la
toiture que le sol avant son
interdiction en 1997 l'amiante était
utilisé dans de nombreux matériaux de
construction car peu coûteuse et très
résistantes peintures enduits isolant
faux plafond tout y passe or ces fibres
d'amiante deviennent très nocives
lorsqu'elles sont inhalées surtout lors
de travaux alors la procédure de
désamiantage et minutieuse pour ne pas
contaminer les ouvriers et le voisinage
déjà de l'amiante il faut se moque dans
un bâtiment l aidant dans les murs dans
l'enduit et pour éviter qu'elle soit
qu'elles se propager partout dans l
enveloppe avec ce qu'on appelle du terme
au sud et la truffe blanche et ensuite
par l'acide qui sera poncé et collectés
par des aspirateurs après la mise à nu
des 5000 mètres carrés de bâtiments
le désamiantage pourra débuter et durera
quatre mois
surmontant 480000 euros sur les trois
millions de budget global une grosse
enveloppe mais monsieur mansour pdg de
la clinique saint paul n'a pas le choix
il veut surtout faire avancer ce vieux
rêve
un projet qu'il mûrit depuis 18 ans je
pense que
réaliser ce pôle de santé sur le site de
saint paul est une pérennisation de
l'activité
je vous rappelle que notre établissement
le plus vieil établissement sanitaire de
l'île 1929 et mon souhait c'est qu'il
puisse affronter son centième
anniversaire
dans son plus bel état une bâtisse est
tout de même conservé dans le cas où
l'offre de reprise de la clinique
sainte-marie serait accepté les travaux
du nouveau pôle de santé débutera à
janvier 2021
il devrait s'achever en juin 2023